[Music]
i really love the show and yet every
time i watch the program i think
how did this show get made it's such a
strange
idea where you the main character is a
serial killer and you root for him
you know
yeah it's amazing it's like they almost
it's like a challenge they say to the
writers come up with a show where you
root for the serial killer and they did
and it's fantastic and it works i never
thought that it would go we were doing
the pilot i thought i was just gonna
like save the money and move on to the
next thing because i couldn't imagine a
network that would champion a serial
killer let alone like audiences that
would root for him so you can tell in
the pilot that you don't think it's
going to go you roll your eyes a lot
yeah you're like let's you actually do
this a lot in the pilot let's move it
along
because this is not going
your character deb drops more f-bombs
than any character
on television no competition
[Applause]
my question is are they because it's
such a smart show cast is so great so
well done a lot of these shows move on
to another life after they've been on on
a showtime or an hbo
and
how are they going to do that with this
show right because in every scene
you come running in with the f-bomb yeah
well they've thought about this and i do
adr you know you do additional recording
where i cover up the bad words just in
case it ever ended up on regular tv on
nickelodeon yeah so instead of
it's going to be on nickelodeon at the
trades today
someone killed spongebob
so
instead of saying like hey you douche
i'll say like hey you peanut butter and
jelly sandwich like what are you doing
here i know i'm really in a bad mouth
today
but that never like when i was i don't
know if you've all seen like when the
sopranos is on now and they they've
changed the words around and it's like
oh you baloney sandwiches
it's not the same yeah you get
very intense and strange fan mail
describe what's one of the strangest
things you've gotten in the mail
um a sailor that was in the navy sent
two enormous and very sharp knives to my
house how he got my address i'll never
know he sent red sharpies for me to sign
and i thought about it for a while and
then i thought one it's inappropriate
that he came over uninvited and two
i don't want to put them back in the
mail so i wrote him a note thanking him
for his service and i kept the knives
and i used them on the regular
use them how oh come on
i've left a trail of murder i don't take
my work home with me uh no but uh that's
weird too he might and he wasn't
irritated that he didn't get it but it's
strange i don't know what his feelings
were about yeah people come up with odd
things for you to sign you know that
that's routine but no i've never heard
of no one's ever sent me giant knives i
would find that a little michael has had
people come up and ask to have their
picture taken with like a knife at their
throat or like a syringe on their throat
so that's interesting
our audience is just like yes what's
wrong with that
we would do that if we saw him as well
what's your point you tweeted a picture
the other day and it's you running with
a parachute behind you and i believe
that's new york city
what's going on here why are you running
with a parachute i'm on vacation
i i wanted everything that interests me
right now i'm trying to take classes in
so i wanted to learn to box and my
boxing coach knows that i'm a runner so
he wants me to run properly before i
start
really boxing so
that's part of it it slows me down so he
can see my form it hurts now wait a
minute it doesn't seem right can't he
just videotape you running and then slow
that down well he does both i think he's
playing i think he's playing a practical
joke on you yeah and getting paid for it
wear this parachute it helps with my
process
so talk about the boxing why why are you
interested in boxing
i don't know a friend of mine was at a
dinner party and she was talking about
how she'd been a boxer for eight years
and i thought that sounds painful i
would like to try it so she gave me her
coach's number and it is so much fun oh
my only problem is i forget that the
other person can hit you back
so i just throw punches and then i
forget that there's gonna be gloves
coming in my now does your trainer
really
hit you back i mean you're an actress
you technically no he hasn't hit me yet
but we're supposed to go into the ring
on friday which is my birthday so that's
how i'm spending my birthday i'm going
to let this guy who's enormous knock me
around in a ring you should talk to
somebody you should get a psychiatrist
quickly
it's my birthday i want a man to beat me